صباح هذا اليوم الاثنين نتجول لمعرفه
الدمار الذي خلفته مقاتلات الاحتلال
الحربيه كذلك مدفعيه الاحتلال كما نتابع
واياكم عبر قناه الجزيره هنا استهدافات
لعدد من المنازل والابراج السكنيه كما
نتابع هذا هذه العماره السكنيه قد طالتها
قذائف الاحتلال ودمرت الطوابق العلويه في
هذا البرج السكني اضافه الى يعني دمار
كبير في الاراضي الزراعيه والطرق الرئيسيه
والشوارع الرئيسيه التي يعني قصفتها
المقاتلات الحربيه صباح اليوم والليله
الماضيه حركه يعني ضعيفه جدا للمواطنين
هنا في هذه المنطقه تحديدا منطقه المدارس
وهو يعني مخيم اثنين بالنصيرات
كما نشاهد واياكم هذه هذا الركام و يعني
الدمار
للابراج السكنيه حيث قصفتها المقاتلات
الحربيه ودبابات الاحتلال قصفت كل شيء في
هذه
المنطقه اتابع واياكم هنا
يعني طواقم الدفاع المدني الان تهرع بشكل
سريع الى المكان
المستهدف في محاوله ل يعني البحث عن
اصابات او ما شابه في هذه
المنطقه
من هذه الجوله في مخيم النصيرات تحديدا
مخيم اثنين بالنصيرات
قناه الجزيره ترصد لكم القصف
والدمار الذي خلفته المقاتلات الحربيه
الليله الماضيه وصباح اليوم منازل
للمواطنين وابراج سكنيه وعمارات سكنيه قد
قصفتها المقاتلات
الحربيه جزء منها مخلى وجزء اخر
هو يعني ماهول بالسكان اصيب عدد من
المواطنين سكان هذه المنازل وقد ارتقى
شهداء تم انتشالهم من قبل طواقم الطبيه
وطواقم الدفاع المدني انتشلوا اعداد من
الشهداء والمصابين باتجاه مشافي المحافظه
الوسطى تحديدا مستشفى العوده ومستشفى
الاقصى بدير البل لازلنا في هذه الجوله في
هذا المخيم والذي يتحدث بعض المواطنين بان
دبابات الاحتلال قد دخلت هذا المخيم صباح
اليوم يعني عبر قناه الجزيره يعني ننفي كل
الشائعات التي تتحدث عن دخول الاليات الى
هذه المنطقه هي منطقه امنه حتى اللحظه ولا
يوجد للاليات في هذه المنطقه يعني اليات
الاحتلال هي على شارع صلاح الدين في
المنطقه الشرقيه التي نتواجد بها شرق يعني
منطقه النصيرات شارع صلاح الدين الفاصل
بين مخيم البريج والنصيرات وهو الش الشارع
الدولي الرئيس في قطاع غزه هذه الاليات
تتواجد في تلك المنطقه ولكن لم تصل الى
المكان الذي يعني نحن بداخله في هذه
اللحظات هو يعني منطقه قد تحدث الاحتلال
عبر منشورات القاها على المواطنين
بمغادرتهم لها بسبب يعني اعمال لجيش
الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه ولكن لم تتقدم
الاليات حتى اللحظه في هذه المنطقه فقط هو
دمار من قبل المقاتلات الحربيه وقصف
لمنازل المواطنين تدمير لابراج سكنيه
تدمير للبنى التحتيه
دون دخول الاليات برا الى هذه المنطقه
التي يعني نسير
بها حتى يعني ننقل
الصوره الصحيحه والصادقه من قلب الميدان
هنا عبر قناه
[موسيقى]
الجزيره
هذا
القصف لعماره سكنيه و الطابق الارضي من
هذه العماره
السكنيه يعني وصلنا الان الى مشارف منطقه
الزوايده لا وجود لاي اليات
للاحتلال قد توغلت برا حسب ما يتح حدث به
بعض المواطنين عبر مواقع التواصل بان
الاليات وصلت الى بلديه الزوايده هنا
بلديه الزوايده لا وجود لاي من الاليات
ولا تواجد لقوات الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه
فقط هو قصف جوي ومدفعي من قبل يعني طائرات
الاحتلال ودبابات الاحتلال
المتوقد على شارع صلاح
الدين